CASEY RODRIGUEZ: We'll continue
our discussion of the Riemann
integral.
So let me just recall
a few bits of notation
from last time and then also,
the main result that we proved
at the end of last class.
So we had partitions,
which are just finite sets.
So here, a is less
than b, and we're
looking at an interval ab.
Partitions, they're
just finite sets of ab.
And then we also had tags,
which were finite sets
as well with c one between
x0 and x1, which is less than
or equal to xi 2, which is less
than or equal to x2 and so on.
And we call these
tag partitions.
And we also had the
norm of a partition.
This is the max of--
so we think of
partitions as being--
as breaking up the interval ab
up into smaller subintervals,
x0 up to x1.
I got to get a different
piece of chalk.
This one is going
psychedelic on me.
And then the xi ones are just
points chosen in these smaller
subintervals.
The norm of a
partition is the length
of the largest subinterval.
And then we had the Riemann sum
associated to a partition, tag
partition xi, which
is the sum from j
equals 1 to n, f xi j
xj minus xj minus 1.
OK?
This just some notation
from last time.
And then what did we prove?
We proved the following
theorem, which
is the existence for the
Riemann integral, which
is the following that for all
continuous functions on ab,
they exist a unique number,
which we denote integral abf
with the property that--
with the following property.
That if I take any
sequence of tag partitions
with norm going to 0--
so this is the partitions
are getting finer and finer.
They're all a sequence of tag
partitions with norms going
to zero, we have the associated
Riemann sums, this sequence
converges.
So this is now a
sequence of real numbers,
and equals this
number, integral abf.
No matter what sequence
of tag partitions
I take with norms
converging to 0,
the Riemann sums converge
to this number, which we
call the Riemann integral of f.
Net, I think the very
last thing we proved
was that the Riemann
integral is linear.
The integral of the sum is
the sum of the integrals.
And if I multiply a continuous
function by a scalar,
then the scalar pulls out.
OK?
So now we're going to discuss
some properties of the Riemann
integral.
So the next is that in some
sense, the area of the union,
if you like, is the
sum of the areas
if we think of the
integral as being
the area underneath the curve.
So this next property
is the additivity
of the Riemann integral,
which states the following--
if f is in cab, and I take
a point between c and b,
then the integral
from a to b of f
is equal to the integral from
a to c of f plus the integral
from c to b of f.
So to prove it,
again, all we know
about these numbers is that
they satisfy this property.
So what we'll do is, we'll take
a sequence of tag partitions
of ac converging to this
integral in a sequence of tag
partitions from c to b
converging to this integral
when I stick them
into the Riemann sums.
But then when I take the
union of those tag partitions,
I get a partition
of ab, which will
approach the integral of ab.
That's the basic intuition.
And of course, what was I
saying a minute ago about area
of the union being
sum of the areas?
Well again, like I said, if we
think of the Riemann integral
as being the area
underneath the curve,
then this says that
the area from a
to b underneath the curve
is equal to the area
underneath the
curve from a to c,
plus the area underneath
the curve from c to b.
OK, so let's take--
someone needs to
write notation here.
Let's take two partitions.
Let be a sequence
of partitions--
so a sequence of tag
partitions, I should say--
of ac such that norm of
this partition goes to 0.
So this is now a
partition of ac.
And then we'll take
another sequence
of tag partitions of cb.
For those watching at home
wondering what these letters
are, that's the Greek eta.
That's the Greek zeta.
So we have a sequence
of partitions of ac.
These are the y and eta.
And then we also have a
sequence of partitions
of cb such that the norm
of these guys go to 0
as well as r goes to infinity.
So now if I have a partition
of ac and a partition of cb,
if I take their union, then
I will get a partition of ab.
This will be the
union of these guys.
So it's easy to see
that this is now
a sequence of tag
partitions of ab.
And moreover, so what is the
norm of this new tag partition?
What is the maximum length
of the subintervals?
Well, it's just going
to be the maximum
of the norms of y and z.
And note that the
norm of x sub r, this
is equal to the maximum of the
norm of yr and the norm of zr.
And since both of these
converges to zero,
the maximum of them
also converges to zero.
So now we just put
this all together.
So by this theorem,
what do we know?
We know that the Riemann sum
associated to this converges
to the integral ab of f.
The Riemann sum associated to
this sequence of tag partitions
converges to acf.
And then, this sequence
of Riemann sums
associated to these tag
partitions converge to cbf.
OK?
And now we just use the fact
that taking a Riemann sum
is additive, right?
Since the Riemann sum associated
to this partition, which
is just a union of these
partitions, is equal to--
this implies taking the
limit as r goes to infinity.
The left hand side, as I wrote
down here, converges to abf.
And then the right hand
side, the limit of the sum
is the sum of the limits.
So this converges to acf.
And then the right thing
here converges to--
the second thing here
converges to the integral
from c to b of f.
And that's it.
So really, the fact that
the integral is additive
follows from the simple fact
that Riemann sums are additive,
and the fact that limits
respect algebraic operations.
The limit of the sum is
the sum of the limits.
All right, so the
Riemann integral
is additive and also linear.
So we see that the
Riemann integral
is something that respects
algebraic operations
with respect to the real numbers
namely, adding and scalar
multiplication.
And it respects I
guess, what you could
say topological considerations.
Or, not really topological,
but this additive property
is a very natural property.
What am I getting at here?
So now one could ask,
how does the integral
interact with inequality?
So this is something we ask
about all limits, right?
Or at least limits of
sequences that we saw.
If one sequence lies
below another one,
taking limits respects that.
Of course, that's not
true for the derivative.
I can have two functions,
one bigger than the other,
and the derivative
of the smaller one
be bigger than the
derivative of the first one.
But so one can ask the
question let's suppose I have
two functions, one
smaller than the other.
What is the-- what's
the relationship
between the integrals?
OK.
So suppose f and g are now two
continuous functions on ab.
So then the first
part of this theorem
is that if for all
x and ab f of x
is less than or equal to g of x,
then the integral from ab of f
is less than or equal to
the integral from ab of g.
All right?
And this is kind
of understandable.
I mean again, if we
think of the integral
as being a theory of the
area underneath the curve.
If I have one function sitting
above another function,
then the area should be bigger
than the area of the smaller
one underneath the curve,
which sits below the first one.
And now the Riemann integral is
a limit of sums in some sense,
and a limit of certain
sums involving f.
And what?
So we do have this
relationship involving
sums and absolute values with
the triangle inequality, which
says the absolute value
of the sum is less than
or equal to the sum of
the absolute values.
And if you think
of the integral as
being essentially in a limit
of sums, or if you like,
a continuous sum,
then you should
expect that the absolute value
of the integral is less than
or equal to the integral
of the absolute value.
And that's indeed what we have.
Second is the absolute
value of the integral
from ab of f is less than or
equal to the integral from ab
of the absolute value of f.
Like this is the triangle
inequality for integrals.
All right, so we'll
prove one, using again,
the main property we
have about Riemann
integrals that they
satisfy this property.
And then we'll deduce two
directly from number one.
So let's take a sequence
of tag partitions
with norms converging to zero.
Then for all r, if we take
the Riemann sum with respect
to f of this tag partition, this
is equal to j equals 1 to n.
This is just the definition.
r here is just indexing the
sequence of tag partitions.
And I should say
this doesn't have
to end at some single number--
in fact, it can't--
in common with all of
these tag partitions.
So here n of r is just the
number of partition points
that we have in our
partition x superscript r.
And since we're assuming f of
x is less than or equal to g
of x for all x and
ab, this is less
than or equal to sum
from j equals 1 to n
of r, g of cj of r.
OK, and what is this last thing?
This last thing is just equal
to the Riemann sum of g,
with respect to this
tag partition x and xi.
So we started off with the
Riemann sum associated to f,
and we showed that's
less than or equal to--
just kind of summarizing here.
That this Riemann
sum is less than
or equal to this Riemann sum.
So now if I take the limit
as r goes to infinity,
this on the left hand side
approaches the integral
from ab.
And since limits
respect inequalities,
I get this, which is
what we wanted to prove.
All right, and from number two--
I mean, for number two,
we get from number one--
I mean, we get number
two from number one,
essentially quite quickly.
So since plus or
minus f is less than
or equal to the
absolute value of f,
we get that plus or minus--
so integral of
plus or minus f is
less than or equal
to the integral
from ab of the absolute value.
Now scalar multiplication we
proved last time pulls out.
So that means plus or
minus the integral of f
is less than or equal to the
integral of the absolute value
of f, which is the same as--
so for the minus sign this
tells me this inequality.
And for the plus sign,
I get that inequality.
But that's equivalent to
saying that the absolute value
of the integral of f is less
than or equal to the integral
of the absolute value.
And that's the proof
of the theorem.
Let me make a
small remark here--
and this will be an exercise
on the homework to prove this--
is the following.
We know that taking
limits respects
inequalities but not
necessarily strict inequalities.
So I can have two
sequences, one strictly less
than the other for all n.
And then as n goes to
infinity, their limits
could in fact equal each other.
So for example, if I
take the first sequence
to be 0, the second sequence
to be 1 over n, 1 over n
is always bigger than zero.
Yet, they both converge to 0.
So taking limits does not
respect strict inequality.
However, in this setting,
which is very nice--
I mean, it's actually an
extremely important property
of the integral is that
this limiting process
that we do to take
integrals in fact does--
it's not just any
old limiting process.
It actually does respect
strict inequality.
So what am I saying?
Is that we can prove something
a little bit stronger.
And that's-- which I'll say
it in its kind of reduced form
here.
If I take a continuous
function and it's positive,
then we already know
that the integral of f
is going to be non-negative
by what we just proved.
But in fact, the integral
of f is positive.
And again, this is also
kind of important from
a psychological standpoint.
If we're thinking
of the integral
as being a theory of the
area underneath the curve.
So what this states is that--
and again, I'm not
going to prove this.
This will be on the assignment.
Again, this coincides
with our intuition
of what a theory of the area
underneath the curve should be.
So this says if a
continuous function
is positive-- like the
picture I drew you--
then the integral, which
we interpret again,
as the area underneath
the curve, is positive.
So that matches what
our desire for this
to be a theory of the area
underneath the curve should be.
All right?
And so we have- if you like--
I mean, we could approve this
from basic considerations
in what the definition
of the integral is.
But we have the
following theorem
that for all alpha and r--
or I could just
say the following.
Well, maybe not stated this way.
Going a little off
script here, but it's OK.
So we actually haven't
computed a single integral yet.
Really, it's tough to
with this definition.
In a minute, we'll prove the
fundamental theorem of calculus
and be able to do
it very easily.
But let me first prove at
least the most basic integral.
So integral from ab of the
function 1 equals b minus a.
So what's the proof?
Take a sequence of partitions
with the norms converging to 0.
And we just look
at the Riemann sum.
And for one this will
be quite easy to compute
what the Riemann sums are.
So this is a sequence
of partitions
with norm converging to 0.
Then if I look at
associated Riemann sums,
this is equal to j
equals 1 to n of r.
No matter what I--
no matter what xi is,
I just get 1, and then times
the length of the interval,
the subinterval.
Now this is a telescoping sum.
Meaning this is equal to x1
minus x0, plus x2, minus x1,
plus up until xn
minus xn minus 1.
So all I pick up is--
not x1-- but x0 and xn.
So this is equal to xj of r
xn, sorry, of r minus x0 of r.
And this is the last
point in the partition.
This is the first
And as always for partitions,
the last point is b.
The first point is a.
So this is equal to b minus a.
Now this thing on the left hand
side is equal to b minus a.
So this tells me that
the integral, which
is equal to this
limit of Riemann sums
is equal to b minus a.
All right, and then the
assignment for this--
or I guess, when you
see this last week,
was to essentially,
compute the integral for--
the integral from ab of x, dx.
And so we get from this theorem
and this theorem following
bound for the area.
So let me draw a picture so
that this is not so surprising.
Let's say I have a
function from a b.
There's the function f.
So that was supposed to
go through this point.
So let's make that
a little bit--
I suppose I don't
need these parts.
Let's say I have-- so far
a continuous function,
it always achieves a
minimum and maximum.
And at least for this picture,
the minimum occurs here.
The maximum occurs here.
Now, what's the comparison
about areas from this picture?
Well, the area
underneath the curve of f
will be bigger than
or equal to the area
underneath the curve of
the constant function
equal to little m sub f.
And that's just b times a times
m sub f, again, by intuition.
But this is also seen from the
theorem we just proved along
with the linearity of
the Riemann integral,
which we've already proved.
And the integral of f, the
area underneath this curve
is also less than or equal to
the area underneath the curve
where f achieves a maximum.
It's the 12th week
of class, and I still
haven't brought colored
chalk, so hopefully, that
was clear enough without me
having to color stuff in.
So the theorem is the following.
If f-- again, we're working
with continuous functions
because that's all we can
integrate or are going
to integrate in this section--
and I have these two numbers,
the inf of fx, which we know
is in fact, a min, meaning
there exist a point in here--
so in fact, I'm going to write
"min." we know that by the min,
max theorem that for
every continuous function
it achieves its minimum--
and max.
Then, as I was
saying a minute ago,
the area underneath
the curve little m sub
f, which is this
smaller square, is
less than or equal to the area
underneath the curve of f.
So little m sub f
times b minus a,
the area underneath
the minimum, is
less than or equal to the area
underneath the curve of f,
which is less than
or equal to the area
underneath the curve of the
taller line, capital M sub f.
How do we prove this?
Well, we just use these
previous two theorems, right?
Since little m sub f is less
than or equal to capital
M sub f--
so since little m sub f is
less than or equal to f of x,
which is less than or
equal to capital M sub f,
for all x and ab we can apply
that theorem up there to get
that the integral of
little m sub f-- again,
this is just a fixed number--
is less than or equal to
the integral from ab of f.
And now again, these
are just fixed numbers.
So by what we proved here that
the integral from a to b of 1
is b minus a, the
fact that scalers
pull out-- so this number
here can come out--
and this is just m sub f times
the integral from ab of one.
So this is little m
sub f times b minus a.
Over here, this is capital
M sub f times b minus a.
And that's the proof.
So now let me make
a few comments
about some conventions, really.
So we've been talking about--
or at least, I've been talking
about, you're not here.
So we haven't been
talking at all.
So we've been talking
about the integral from ab
to f when a is less than
b, But I'm going to use--
I'm just going to set
down some convention,
or you could say this
is really notation.
When I have this--
when I write down this symbol,
integral a to a of f, this
is really just another
way of writing 0.
And another is that if,
in fact, b is less than a,
then the integral from ab to f--
so remember, we've been talking
about the integrals from--
over intervals-- or where
the number on the bottom
is less than the
number on the top,
so whenever I write this
symbol with the bigger
number on the bottom and the
smaller number on the top,
you should read this as
minus the integral of,
with this being in
the right place,
meaning this number here is
less than this number here.
OK and so again, these
are really just notations,
that if I write this, this
is a fancy way of writing 0.
When I write this, this
means minus the integral
with the right numbers
on top and bottom,
meaning the smaller numbers
on the bottom, the bigger
numbers on the top.
So maybe you ask-- so this is--
so why do I define that to be 0.
Well, if you like, 1 is
consistent with the fact
that for all
continuous functions,
if I take the integral from
a to b with b bigger than a,
and I take the limit as b
goes to a, this equals 0.
And two is then consistent with
number one and then additivity.
With additivity in number one,
because then by number one,
I get that the--
so additivity will tell me that
the integral from a to a of f
is equal to the
integral from ab to f,
plus the integral from baf,
here assuming b is less than a.
So if by 1 this is 0, then to
be consistent with additivity,
this would force
the integral from ab
to f to be minus the
integral from ba of f.
So both of these
conventions, if you like,
are consistent with the
properties of the Riemann
integral, namely
that the limit as b
goes to a of the area
underneath this curve,
as the base gets smaller
and smaller is 0.
And then from--
if I assume this,
then additivity tells me
that the integral from ab
has to be minus the
integral from b to a of f.
All right, so now we computed
successfully one integral.
Of course, when you took
calculus, that was not all
you could do.
Calculus is what it is because
of the hero of the story, which
is Fundamental
Theorem of Calculus,
which is what we'll prove now.
Fundamental Theorem of Calculus,
which states following.
If I have a function big F--
so first off, let little
f be continuous function.
So the first
statement is basically
how to compute integrals.
If capital F
integral from ab to r
is differentiable everywhere on
ab and f prime equals little f,
then the integral
from ab of little f
equals f of b minus f of a.
Another way of saying
this is that the integral
from ab of capital F prime is
equal to f of b minus f of a.
And then the second
part-- so the first part
is about computing integrals.
The second part is about
solving differential equations,
basically.
So the function g of x equals
the integral from a to x of f.
So for each x and ab, I stick
it in as the upper limit
on this integral.
This function is
differentiable on ab.
And it satisfies the
simplest differential
equation, which is g prime
equals f, and g of a equals 0.
So this is the
Fundamental Theorem
of Calculus, the first
part being about how do you
compute integrals, the second,
how do you compute solutions
to a differential equation.
Namely, how do I find the
solution to the problem
g prime equals little f.
So little f is the given.
I want to find a function g that
satisfies g prime equals little
f with initial condition
capital G of a equals 0.
That's given by this function
here where I take little left
and I integrate it from a to x.
So that's how I interpret
the Fundamental Theorem
of Calculus, the first
about solving integrals,
the second about solving
differential equations.
All right so this is
the hero of calculus,
the Batman of the story.
And I said at one point
that the Mean Value Theorem
is the Alfred of this story.
And therefore, it should
play a decisive role
in proving this theorem.
All right.
So we're going to
connect these two things.
So in order to even
get at this guy,
we have to take a partition,
a sequence of partitions
converging with norm
converging to 0.
So and then see what we get.
So this is the proof part one.
So let's take a sequence
of tag partitions--
I keep forgetting to write
tag and say the word tag,
but you should hear that
even though I don't say it--
with norm.
Actually, we're
not even going to--
this is correct.
I'm actually going to come
up with the tags in a minute.
So let's first take a
sequence of partition.
So this is actually
completely correct.
So no tags yet, no
points chosen in between,
with Norm converging to 0.
And then I'm going to choose
a special tag for each r
so that in the limit I get this
equality between the integral
of f and capital F of b
minus f, capital F of a.
So here comes Alfred by
the Mean Value Theorem.
So we have this subinterval
x of j minus 1 and x sub j.
So by the Mean Value
Theorem, there exist--
for each j there exists a
point in between these two guys
such that if I take f
of x sub j r minus f--
so capital F, remember,
is this function
that's differential and whose
derivative gives me little f--
this is equal to
capital F prime of xi j
of r times xj minus xj minus 1.
And by assumption, the
derivative of capital F
is equal to little f, right?
So I'm going to replace
this f prime with little f.
So now these xi's I will take
as my tag, my sequence of tags.
Put a star by this
relation here.
What do we conclude?
If I look at the Riemann
sum for f associated
to now this sequence of
tags, where now the xi's are
exactly these xi's that
satisfy this relation.
This is equal to as
before, sum from j
equals 1 to nr f of xg xi sub j.
Now by how these xi's
were chosen-- remember,
they were chosen to satisfy
this relation here, star
by the Mean Value Theorem.
So this is equal to the sum
from j equals 1 two n sub
r, f of x sub j minus
f of x sub j minus 1.
And again, this is
a telescoping sum.
And so all I pick up is when j
equals n of r, the last point.
And when j equals 0-- so this
is equal to f of the last point
minus f of the first point.
Now for partition,
this is always b.
And this is always a.
So this is f of b minus f of a.
So every one of these Riemann
sums for this sequence of tag
partitions gives me
f of b minus f of a
So then I get to take the
limit, and I get the integral.
And therefore,
integral from ab to f,
which is limited as r goes to
infinity of s of f equals--
and we just computed
this is always
equal to f of b minus f of a.
We took a sequence
of-- just a recap--
we took a sequence of partitions
with norms converging to 0.
And we chose special tags
using the Mean Value Theorem.
So by the Mean Value
Theorem, on each one
of these subintervals capital F
evaluated at the right endpoint
minus f evaluated
at the left endpoint
is equal to f, which is
the derivative of capital
F evaluated at some
point in between times
the length of the interval.
So now if we take the
Riemann sum associated
to this sequence
of tag partitions
where these xi's are
defined by this condition,
then we can actually
compute this Riemann sum,
and it just gives me f of
b minus f of a no matter
what r is.
So then when I take the
limit as r goes to infinity,
the left side goes
to the integral,
but it's always equal to
capital F of b minus f of a.
So that proves number one.
So for number two, what
do we want to show?
We want to show this function.
So first off, it's
by convention g
of a, which is the integral
from a to a of f, this is zero.
So I don't have to check
the second condition.
I just need to check that this
function is differentiable,
and the derivative of
that function is little f.
Let c be in ab.
So what do we want to show?
We want to show the
derivative of capital
G is equal to little f.
So we would like to show
that the limit as x goes
to c of the integral from a to
x of f minus integral from a
to c of f, over x minus c, which
is just g of x minus g of c,
equals f of c.
so we're going to do
this by the books--
by the book, I guess.
When I say-- so that's
kind of a bad pun, I guess.
I don't know.
But meaning, an epsilon
delta proof for this limit.
So let epsilon be positive.
The Delta that we pick
in the end depends on--
and we'll use crucially the
fact that f is continuous at c.
So since f is
continuous at c, there
exists a delta 0
positive such that what?
t minus c less than
delta 0 implies
that f of t minus f of
c is less than epsilon--
let's give ourselves a
little room-- over 2.
Choose delta to be this delta 0.
Remember, we have to
show for every epsilon,
there exists a delta so that if
x minus c is less than delta,
then this minus this in absolute
value is less than epsilon.
I'm now saying, choose
delta to be this delta 0
where this delta 0 is
ensuring this right here.
OK as long as t minus
C is less than delta 0.
Now because of sign
conventions, we'll do two cases.
So not really, I'm just
going to do one case.
So suppose that x is
between c and c plus delta.
So we want to also show--
we'll also need to be
able to do the case that x
is between c minus delta and c.
That would cover the whole
range of the absolute value
of x minus c is less than
delta but bigger than zero.
I'm just going to do this case.
So now we want to show
that if x is in here,
then this thing minus this
thing in absolute value
is less than epsilon.
So first off, I
would like to note
that if t is in this interval
c to x, then that tells me
that the absolute value of
t minus c, which is equal
just t minus c, this is less
than or equal to x minus c,
which is less than delta.
And remember, this equals
delta 0, all right?
So as long as I'm in
this interval here,
the absolute value of t
minus c is less than delta 0.
So let me just draw a picture
so that this is pretty clear.
This length is delta.
If I take any t in between,
then this distance from t to c
is also going to
be less than delta.
So that's all I've written down.
Thus, by now compute
the difference quotient
minus the proposed limit.
So looking at 1 over x minus
c times the integral minus
the integral from ac
of f minus f of c.
This is the thing I want to
show is less than epsilon.
Now by additivity, the integral
from a to x since x is--
well, the integral
from a to x of f
is equal to the integral
from a to c plus the integral
from c to x.
So this is equal to 1
over x minus c integral
from c to x of f minus fc.
Now, this is just
a fixed number.
And therefore, I'm going
to do a little trick.
Minus the integral from--
so in fact, let me do this.
Let me throw in some
integration variables
so that this becomes clearer.
So this is f of t, dt minus
integral of f of t, dt.
I've been using
the notation where
I just don't write down
the integration variable,
but let me do that here.
F of t, dt minus f of c.
Now this is equal to minus f
of c over x minus c integral
from c to x of 1 dt.
Because the integral from
c to x of the constant 1
gives me x minus c.
That cancels with this guy.
Now f of c is just a number.
It's just a fixed number.
So I can bring this
inside the integral.
And then use the linearity
of the integral to in fact,
rewrite all of this as 1
over the absolute value
of x minus c integral from c
to x of f of t minus f of c,
dt in absolute value.
Now 1 over x minus
c, this is positive
because x is bigger than c.
So I can pull this
out just like that.
And now what do I know?
For t in between this c and x,
the absolute value of t minus c
is less than delta 0, right?
So by what I have here, as long
as I'm in this interval cx,
I'm going to have
this inequality hold.
So before I do that, let
me first apply the triangle
inequality for integrals.
This is less than or equal
to the integral from c
to x of f of t minus f of c.
So by the second thing
that I've underlined,
for t in this interval
c to x, this thing
here is always less
than epsilon over 2.
So by what we know about
integrals respecting
inequalities, this is
going to be less than
or equal to 1 over integral
x minus c, integral c
to x, epsilon over 2 dt.
And now this is just equal to--
so this is a number.
It comes out.
So I get 1 integral
from c to x of 1.
So I get x minus c
times the integral of 1.
So x minus c, and that
cancels, less than epsilon.
And this was for x between
c and c plus delta.
The argument for c between
c and c minus delta
is essentially the same,
just with minor sign changes.
So similarly, c minus
delta less than c
implies that the
integral from a to x
of f minus integral a to c of
f over x minus c minus f of c
is less than epsilon.
So we've done x between c minus
delta and c, x between c and c
plus delta, which
implies that if--
then, which is what
we wanted to prove.
OK, so we've concluded the proof
of the Batman of the story.
And this gives us not only a
way of computing integrals,
but useful way of, if you
like, shifting the burden
or shifting the
blame whenever we
do compute the integrals
of certain products.
So what I'm talking
about is the integration
by parts, which I
can't remember if I
said it was first or second.
I think he was second.
First most useful
thing from analysis
is the triangle inequality,
the second being integration
by parts.
And a close third being the
Cauchy-Schwartz inequality,
which in conjunction with
integration by parts is quite
a--
most current research papers
are based on these two things
and using them in
a very clever way.
So integration by
parts is suppose f
and g are continuously
differentiable,
what that means is that the
derivatives exists on ab,
and they're also continuous.
So if you hear me
say continuously
differentiable in
the future that
means that the function has a
derivative that's continuous.
Then the integral from
ab of f prime times
g-- so the one with the
burden, because remember,
differentiablity is
kind of a miracle.
So miracles always come
with some sort of burden.
This is equal to f
of b times g of b
minus f of a times g of a
minus the integral from a to b.
And now we shift that
burden to g times g prime.
So let me put a parentheses
around that so you can--
I don't-- let's do it
this way, g prime f.
All right, so I can take that
derivative and put it on g.
And what's the proof?
The proof is just the
Fundamental Theorem of Calculus
and the product rule.
Since the derivative
of f times g
is equal to f prime times
g plus g prime times f,
we get by the Fundamental
Theorem of Calculus
the integral from ab of,
let's say the right hand side,
so this is f prime
g plus g prime f
is equal to the integral from
a to b of f times g prime,
so by Fundamental
Theorem of Calculus.
And now the integral
of the derivative
is the function evaluated
at the endpoint.
So that's f of b times g of
b minus f of a times g of a.
So that's integration
by parts, which
is a consequence of
the product rule.
the quotient rule is something--
is just really the product
rule in disguise kind of.
So we don't get really
anything new from there.
But we also remember,
have the chain
rule, which then results in the
change of variables formula.
So theorem-- let b from ab to cd
be continuously differentiable.
So this means the
function is continuous,
and its derivative
is also continuous.
With the property that the
derivative is positive on ab.
b of a equals c.
b of b equals d.
It's hard to see that a.
So you can think of phi as being
a change of variables from cd
to ab.
Then the integral
from c to d of f of u,
du is equal to the
integral from a
to b of f of phi of
x, phi prime of x, dx.
So maybe instead of
change of variables--
so this is change
of variables, a.k.a.
u substitution, where you
said u equal to phi of x,
then du is equal to
phi prime of x dx.
And again, the
proof of this just
follows from the
Fundamental Theorem
of Calculus and the
chain rule that we know.
So let f be a function
from ab to r such that
f prime equals little f.
We can always find
one by the second part
of the Fundamental
Theorem of Calculus.
We can always solve this
differential equation up
to a constant.
Then if I look at the
function f of phi of x,
and I take its derivative with
respect to x by the chain rule,
this is equal to f
prime of phi of x
times phi prime
of x, which equals
f of phi of x, phi prime of x.
So then when I integrate that,
integral from ab, phi of x--
f of phi of x phi
prime of x dx, this
is equal to the integral from
ab of f of phi of x prime dx.
Now by part one of the
Fundamental Theorem
of Calculus, this is equal to--
the integral of the
derivative is this thing
evaluated at the endpoint.
So f of phi of b
minus f of phi of a.
This is equal to f of d
minus f of c because phi of b
equals d, phi of a equals
c, and phi of b equals d.
But again, by the Fundamental
Theorem of Calculus
since capital F is--
when you differentiate,
it gives me little f,
this is equal to the integral
from c to d of f prime of u du,
which is equal to f of u du.
Again, so we just applied the
Fundamental Theorem of Calculus
really, three times, OK?
First to find a function
whose derivative is little f.
Then we used the
chain rule to conclude
that the derivative
of capital F of phi
equals this thing, which is
the thing we're integrating
on the right hand side.
So then when we
integrate that, that's
equal to the integral
of a derivative.
And therefore, we just
pick up the endpoints,
f of d minus f of c.
But because capital
F is equal to--
is an anti-derivative
of little f,
meaning it's
derivative is little f,
this number here is also
equal to this integral here,
which is this guy.
And so then we get the
change of variables formula.
So I think we'll stop there.
And next time, we'll
do a quick application
of the second most
useful thing on Earth,
which is integration by parts.
And then we'll move on to
sequences of functions.